hello everyone and welcome to an amazing
game that just ended from the tournament
of pce round six that is being played in
Zagreb Croatia it is Bulgarian grandmas
Ian chaparo with the white pieces
against Hans miman and Hans is having a
sensational tournament he going into
this round he's on four and a half out
of um five which is which is absolutely
incredible at this level and he's
playing uh like I said Bulgarian Grand
Master Ian chaparo rated 2649 10 points
um lower than niman none of them are um
the top seat of the tournament top seat
of the tournament is actually Anon
korobov at
2667 uh but yeah we already covered two
games by HTS if you haven't seen them
check out in the previous video where I
also discuss a little bit about the
history of the tournament some of you
found that very interesting so if you
haven't heard or seen it do check it out
uh but yeah let's check out this game
only 25 moves uh one slight mistake
mistake causes um the loss of this game
so let's see what happened so Ian has
the wi pieces and he opens with Pawn to
C4 he goes for the English opening
Knight to F6 we have Knight to C3 and
pawn to E5 and the two knights variation
of the English Knight F3 and Knight to
C6 going into the Four Knights variation
of the English G3 the so-called fanal
line and Bishop to B4 we have Knight to
D5 uh Bishop to G2 is the main move here
chiarino tries Knight to D5 against Hans
and now we have Pawn to E4 and this is
very tricky and not a lot of games
featuring this move but it has been
played by some very strong players for
example Leon Aran played it against
Anish giri vishan Anan played it against
hiar Nakamura Kasparov played it against
laier Karana played against T Peno and
you know with mixed results and here
there are two ways of dealing with this
sometimes Knight captur some B4 was
played but nowadays it is known that
Knight to H4 is the top idea because if
you go for Knight captures on B4 and
Knight captures on B4 then Knight to D4
as the Knight moved from the defense of
the D4 Square for example you will
castle and and after A3 and knights to
C6 he will double up Black's pawns here
uh but it's not much the E4 Pawn is
incredibly strong so it prevents white
from playing D4 and it's just going to
be a very nice game for black so Knight
to H4 is considered the main move here
which is what chaparo plays and now we
have castles and pawn to A3 asking what
do you do with the bishop and here there
is one game that was actually played in
the grand Swiss that just finished
between paramu and Rak sadani sadani
played Bishop to A5 and he won that game
but here we have Bishop to C5 and it is
not as of move seven already that we
have a completely new game so one thing
that's interesting about Bishop to A5
that sadani played is that you cannot
trap the bishop B4 Bishop to B6 and you
don't have C5 because the Knight on D5
would hang and if you capture on F6
first with check you still don't have
this because the Rook is hanging and of
course if you play Rook to B1 uh uh
let's not forget about our good friend
the bishop you get checkmated on F2 uh
so that's the point well uh Bishop to A5
is playable
uh the main move by the engine is
retreating the bishop to E7 then to C5
then to D6 and only then to A5 so much
like you would have in the Evans Gambit
for example and now Bishop to C5 uh we
have Bishop to G2 and now Pawn to D6 we
have castles Rook to E8 of course
getting the Rook into the game adding
more support to the E Pawn and now D3 we
have e captures on D3 and okay like we
said this is like a big bone in White's
throat so if white can play D3 and not
goes wrong then white is perfectly fine
so Hans plays e captures on D3 and now
Queen captures on D3 you could also play
sorry you could also play e captures and
D3 then let's say Knight captures Bishop
captures and you play Knight to D4 and
this is now an incredibly strong piece
C6 will we played Bishop can come to H3
The Rook controls the file is just a
very strong position for black so
instead Queen captures on D3 is played
and now we have Knight to E5 attacking
the queen here Queen to C2 and now Pawn
to C6 chasing away the Knight
and uh what do you do with the Knight
the problem is if you play Knight back
to C3 then you're no longer guarding the
C4 pawn and if you play Knight captures
on F6 then Queen captures on F6 and
again uh how are you playing this if you
play something like Pawn to E4 remember
Bishop to E6 and you don't have
sufficient uh uh uh resources to defend
the C4 Pawn of course B3 will be met
with simple Knight captures because that
Rook on A1 is always hanging since white
waited so long with the development of
the dark Square Bishop so Knight to C3
is played with the idea okay let Hans
capture on C4 we're going to move the
Knight and we're going to have some
pressure along the C file and Hans goes
for it Knight captures on C4 and now
Knight to A4 putting pressure on the
bishop and opening up an attack towards
the Knight so Hans plays Bishop to E6 he
defends the Knight and now what you
should play is just capture the bishop
which was your goal all along Knight
captures D captures and you play B3 you
kick away the Knight Knight goes back
and then you play Rook to D1 the game
continues black will always be a little
bit better as black is up a pawn but uh
okay black white does have the bishop
pair so uh all in all should be an equal
game however after Bishop D6 uh even
chiarino decided not to go for the
capture right away he wanted to improve
the position first with Rook to D1 as
now Knight captures on C5 will be a huge
threat the D Pawn is now pinned but he
missed one critical move by Hans that
wins him the game so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for hunts
while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures an F2 with cck and now I I I
Believe I Can Feel chaparo Spain when he
saw this move and he was like why didn't
I just capture on C5 first and then when
Rook to B1 why did I play Rook to D1
first and allow this abomination of a
move uh because now you see all of the
moves that are coming like Knight Knight
is coming coming to G4 Knight is coming
to E3 you control it twice I mean so
many moves are now now happening and
worst of all uh is a move that I'm not
going to tell you what it is you're
going to see it for yourselves look at
this King captures on F2 and now Knight
to G4 with check King to G1 is sort of
the move that should be played here but
um chaparo played King to E1 and now
comes Pawn to B5 and this is the move
that makes it problematic because
there's no good way of solving the
position here problem is the natural
Knight to C3 is met with Queen to B6 and
now how do you stop Queen F2 Checkmate
the Knight is covering D2 have to play
something like E4 for the queen to cover
the F2 square but now Pawn to D5 you
open up the position and the white king
gets absolutely crushed here uh another
thing you could after B5 you could say
all right let's let's just leave the
Knight here let's go Bishop captures and
C6 attack some Rooks here on on A8 and
E8 but now just B captures on A4 that's
the point and if Bishop captures on E8
you don't care Queen B6 again there is
no defense here whatever you play is
just um it's just insufficient so that's
the issue here and uh uh so after this
PA to B5 move chaparo have said all
right let's go Rook to D4 and it is a
very clever idea because now if Hans
just wins the Knight on A4 then Rook
captures and C4 was planned and if
Bishop captures Queen captures then okay
white still H can fight um not uh not
not a lot happening here he does have
two pieces for The Rook so he can fight
he does have a bit of a weak King on E1
maybe he can survive this but Hans will
not allow it after Rook to D4 Hans plays
Knight C to E3 and attacks the queen and
the bishop on G2 so of course you have
to trade Bishop captures on E3 other
Knight captures on E3 and now Queen to
C3 and now comes the real problem uh you
don't have to play Queen to C3 but you
don't really have uh all that many great
squares you could go to to D2 then
Knight captures on G2 will be a problem
just followed by Pawn captures on A4 so
Queen to C C3 is played to put pressure
on the Knight here uh but it doesn't
really do all that much and here Hans
plays a very very tricky move uh Bishop
to D5 not rushing anything just
defending his Knight on E3 and uh the
bishop here is much much stronger than
you would think this is such a
complicated line uh let's uh you know
let's ask the silly question here
because you know asking dumb questions
is actually how you grow and how you
gain success in chess uh what happens if
we just capture it well okay let's play
Bop captures on D5 the point is that
after C captures on D5 and let's say
Rook D3 now you are asking the Knight to
move politely there's this nasty D4 idea
and now if the queen captures Knight to
C2 check wins the queen and if the Rook
captures then you are no longer
threatening to win the Knight and I just
Rook to C8 you kick away the queen you
don't even have to play this you kick
away the queen you play Knight to C2
with a triple monster Fork here then you
capture The Rook then you capture the
Knight or you just Checkmate the white
king anything is possible here uh so
that's why after Bishop to D5 you can't
just capture it so what was played was
Bishop to E4 a very tricky move by
chiarino now disconnecting the Rook
defending the Knight on E3 threatening
Queen captures on E3 but Hans plays
Bishop captures on e4 Queen captures on
E3 and now just Bishop back to D5 again
uh with deadly purpose now the queen has
to move and still B captures on A4
happens at the end of the day Queen to
D2 was played uh B captures on A4 and
it's not that Hans won a piece or
anything now it's equal material uh uh
regarding pieces Hunt is up to pawns but
the white king is still in a terrible
situation here Rook captures on A4 was
played and now Hans played this very
tricky Rook to E5 move that uh serves
many purposes now at first glance it
seems like you're just planning to
Triple up here on the E file Queen E7
Rook to E8 uh but there is even a
greater purpose here Rook to D4 was
played uh and now Hans just nicely
finished the game with Pawn to G5 as the
Knight is now trapped uh and there is
nothing nothing you can do you cannot
Retreat to G2 it's covered by the bishop
if you go to F3 of course again just
Bishop captures here the pawn cannot
move uh other squares are now taken the
Rook covered F5 that was the point one
of the points of Rook D5 and yeah
there's nothing to do here 25 moves
huntt defeats a very very strong 2649
grandmas even chaparo from Bulgaria with
the black pieces like I said in 25 moves
but uh I know some of you I like it when
I show you why a position is so so um
Superior let's say he didn't blunder the
piece here with Rook to D4 let's say he
actually played something like King to
F2 just unpinning and also the Knight
can now go to G2 as the king also helps
out with the defense uh you're just
going to continue with your plan of
tripling up on the E file let's say
Knight back to F3 you can even capture
here captures captur and Rook to E8 look
at this look at this I mean this is so
massive uh you have to block with Rook
to E4 you can simply capture Queen will
capture here if Queen captures on D6 he
will play Queen to E2 with check King to
G1 Queen captures on beat you and now it
could be a little bit tricky but yeah
The Rook is hanging you have to move the
Rook now you're going to defend your
pawns Queen to B6 check King G2 and G6
you will create some breathing room for
your king you defend the pawns and now
it's merely a matter of technique and of
course um chiarino knows that Hans has
all the technique uh needed to win this
let's say queen to D7 uh you will go
Rook to E2 check and after King H3 now
even C5 threatening a queen trade here a
queen trade always um winning for black
so Queen C8 check let's say and here
after you go for some sort of a slack
Fest here threatening Checkmate Rook G8
check you will deliver some checks here
and after Queen cap on C5 F5 Queen to
G1 uh uh to defend against Checkmate on
H2 sorry about that you will play Queen
C2 and now there is no defense against
Checkmate here uh so yeah brilliantly
done by Hans uh five and a half out of
six incredible run we'll see if he can
keep this up for the entire tournament
three more runs to go I mean this would
even be the this would even be better
than than Fischer's result in 1970 that
when he played but yeah we'll see what
happens uh and if he continues his
Onslaught and he continues playing this
uh this powerful chess we will of course
cover uh all the other games as well so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it incredible stuff by Hans I
would like to thank David gasparian Yen
piano on YouTube Joel LX mehmed haki
usali and Karim kawash for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that's happening in the Chess World and
of course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your
day